that was too hot don't eat directly off
the griddle people that's really stupid
oh
my name is george moss my job is to take
what's up here
and put it right in there
in your brain let's have some fun with
hamburger history
are you ready for this it's another
topping speed round
four burgers wait oh yeah actually sir
i think i just pulled a muscle in my
nose four
more smash burgers with regional
toppings
if you're thinking to yourself like okay
george how many more of this god
damn toppings rounds can you do i can do
this forever
these are real time tested
regional favorites from around the
country you're gonna love this
we're gonna make the pimento
cheeseburger from south carolina
the bacon avocado burger from california
the goober burger from missouri
and marty's combo also from california
let's do this
zoom yeah first up femena cheeseburger
from south carolina i say south carolina
yeah that's right i have southern blood
in me
i'm rooted in south carolina because of
my mom
because of that i have a very fond
appreciation for southern food
namely pimento cheese in the south it
shows up on everything
eventually pimento cheese made its way
to a burger which makes perfect sense
melty pimento cheese is like nothing
else on a burger it's pretty amazing
there's so many different recipes for
fermented cheese but one of my personal
favorites
is from my mom hey georgie how'd you
know it's me
i thought your your face shows up on my
screen oh
you know what we're doing we're making
uh cheeseburgers with a very special
kind of cheese
what is it mom i know it's banana cheese
pimento cheese why is it not pimento
cheese
you mean as in pronouncing the tea like
pimento
[Music]
if you said that where i come from then
know you from off
off you know you're from off you're from
off somewhere
oh so wait define that's a good one
though define being
off like what are the stages of being in
the south
well if you're born on the peninsula of
charleston where i was born right on
colonial lake in the hospital there
you're from raichan
if you're from like another part of the
state like up in conway or something
you're from a way away if you're out of
the state you're just from off
[Music]
what is your recipe tell me your recipe
oh well you didn't tell me you're gonna
ask me that but
i think i think my feminine cheese is
just cheddar
and a whole jar of pimentos with with um
a juice
and mayonnaise right hot sauce and hot
sauce
and cream cheese i never made it with
cream cheese until you taught me
oh but so your version does not have
cream cheese in it
no but i like it with cream cheese it's
good thanks mom we're gonna go make
a med cheeseburger now in your honor
okay okay
all right see y'all later bye pimento
cheese
keep up it's gonna be fast ready block
cheddar cheese you want to shred it
yourself
don't buy the pre-shredded crap you want
to make sure you add
mayonnaise and you also want to add
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
next i want to take some blocks of cream
cheese
and lots and lots of pimentos these are
actually sweet pimentos
in their own juice most really good
pimento cheese has hot sauce in it
i'm using look at this shout out calaba
and mix incorporate
okay now smash burger
salt oh look at that
flip and cheese amanda cheese
oh i'm gonna cover to melt
and toast or toasting perfectly oh look
at that
you hear that that's the sound of
melting happening see how we're doing
oh look at that
oh yeah oh baby wow way
wow that's pretty accurate
found a cheeseburger from south carolina
mama's recipe okay
oh
look coming home
oh yeah um
that's so good but we gotta move number
two
next up the bacon avocado burger you're
thinking uh come on george why am i
putting an avocado in a burger
there's actually a place in california
that still makes a bacon avocado burger
that's right bacon
and avocado and a burger avocado
actually does work on a burger though
you're thinking well just another green
thing no not at all
avocado contains something called oleic
acid you want to get real scientific
oleic acid is an 18 carbon chain fatty
acid there it is
and this is actually why beef tastes so
good
guess what oleic acid is also present
in avocados that's right do i understand
what any of this means
no first bacon
watch this bacon in the round fold it
twice
and look at that now that will fit on
your burger
ball of beef and smash
my mom taught me to twist
oh look at that
didn't work again there you go out it
comes
look at that
[Laughter]
brand is misfiring oh god cheese
if you go to howard's bacon avocado
which is this funny little place in a
strip mall
right near the 405 in los angeles
the first thing you're going to find
mayonnaise in the bottom of the bun
then a slice of tomato fresh buttery
avocado
got some bacon in the round here leaf
lettuce
southern california loves their crunchy
iceberg i tell ya
oh yeah the bacon avocado
oh and true to southern california
hamburger style we're going to wrap this
up
with wax paper and enjoy it while
driving down the 405
one head on the wheel and one hand on a
bacon avocado cheeseburger look at that
beautiful thing look at that
[Applause]
oh
this is so good but we're on to the next
let's go speed round
cooper burger the goober burger from
missouri
unfortunately the place that i learned
about the goober burger has closed
moment of silence yeah that sucks
the wheel in drive-in of sedalia
missouri was a place that served
the goober burger a peanut butter
covered
burger now you're probably thinking ugh
that sounds disgusting it does sound
kind of gross but think
peanuts in pad thai think beef satay
when you put these things together oily
nuts
that doesn't sound quite right
[Laughter]
when you put these things together beef
flavor
peanuts salty a little bit of sweetness
in there
peanut oil nut oils
[Music]
[Laughter]
these actually go a long way in creating
an amazing flavor profile unfortunately
the wheel in driving closed and it
closed
because of you're not gonna believe this
highway expansion they had to actually
put a turning lane right where the
restaurant was so unceremoniously
it was knocked down that makes me so sad
because the turning lane
in a road is more important than
hamburger history
that's what i say but we can relive that
moment
right here let's make one ready we're
gonna toast the bun
smash burger this little salt
salty bowls sorry inappropriate
but smash when i asked the owner what
kind of peanut butter sauce or what is
the
what is the concoction here he said it's
just gif
so what did you say and my camera guy
said
he said it's just jiff that's all it is
it's just
hot store-bought peanut butter that's
all it is
flip then goober what they do is they
actually goober it right on the flat top
so i'm going to dope the bun with some
pickles
yes the goober burger from sedalia
missouri
oh wow oh cooked peanuts
are incredible and because it's peanut
butter it goes into all the cracks and
crevices of that burger
oh so good
have you ever had peanut butters and
pickles
that is worth it
oh so good on to the next one more to go
it's the combo from marty's the combo
you know why it combines two of
america's favorite foods
the hot dog and the hamburger together
it's a hamburger hot dog or hot dog
hamburger
do i need a hot dog do we need a
hamburger get the combo
marty's is the home of the combo or if
you look at one side of the building it
says the home of the comb
because they did some duct work and they
covered up the o in the side so now it
just says
marty's home of the comb i don't know
why i think it's so funny why is that
funny
that's kind of funny right because if
you don't know any better you'd think
that they sold
hair products but to me chili
and cheese and hot dogs and hamburgers
all go together
especially since la is the place that
invented chili that's right and that's
exactly why when you go to marty to get
the combo
you get the combo with chili and cheese
and fart your way all the way home
that's right
the first thing they do at marty is they
take a hot dog and they butterfly it see
that it's been
i've cut this right down the center it
goes
onto the flat top get that nice and
greely smash your hamburger
bounce that's some fresh meat it bounced
that one a little bit of salt not too
much salt because there's a lot of salt
in that hot dog right there
toast a bun the reason you toast a bun
is to make sure you can
create a prophylactic barrier so the
juices cannot escape
the burger that's exactly why you do it
give it a smash
american cheese on the flip beef chili
beef hot dog
beef ow burger jesus i can't see
am i losing my sight
you're probably thinking okay this silly
long hot dog in this round burger what
happens next i'll see exactly what they
do
at marty's they cut a butterflied hot
dog
in half now you have a square
that will actually fit perfectly on that
burger see that look at that
let's try to put this in together now oh
chili chili is very basic chili is just
crumbled
cooked beef sugar water tomato paste
chili powder and
hot sauce of course a little bit of hot
sauce watch the build here we go
the cheeseburger patty our little
hot dog pieces and on top of that oh
[ __ ] hot uh we put chili
beef chili on a beef hot dog
and a beef patty holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
hmm this is the epitome of comfort food
and it's probably super hot oh [ __ ]
guess what it tastes exactly how you
think it would
amazing
marty's one of the very last walk-up
burger stands in los angeles at one
point there must have been thousands of
them
today there's under 10
under 10. so go and patronize a place
like marty's because
it's one of the last of the living
legends in los angeles
that's it we did it four
more regional smash burgers for you
well for me go make them
don't stop looking at me i'll see you
next time
on burger scholar sessions let's have
some fun
hey my name is george moats don't forget
to like and subscribe to first we feast
and get more episodes of burger scholar
right here
where